[Música]
finalmente salud volvió a este espacio
de france 24 directo a mary que ya está
conmigo en el estudio más romeros a la
que no se ha ido
aquí está porque la hemos tenido también
haciendo pues los análisis no también de
lo que ocurre en esta guerra pero vamos
con las noticias de salud que tanta
falta nos hacían mar porque ese se
detectó una variante del vídeo seco y 19
que mezcla delta con o micro en la
detección vamos a hacer cuatro apuntes
rápidos sobre estas noticias que hemos
olvidado que hemos dejado pasar durante
todo este conflicto
delta cron es un hombre que
efectivamente puede parecer bastante
temible no que asusta un poco pero en
realidad no hay tanto motivo de
preocupación y eso es lo que venimos a
explicar hoy se trata una variante
híbrida de el coronavirus que combina
gen genes tanto de la variante delta
como de la variante omicron de hecho
delta crono no es su nombre oficial sino
es el nombre como mediático que se le ha
dado y esto en realidad se trata de un
virus recombinante que puede suceder
cuando se mezclan en una misma célula
dos virus distintos de variantes
distintas decir que una misma persona
está infectada de dos variantes
distintas por ahora la organizada
mundial de la salud sólo la ha
clasificado como variante de monitoreo
que se trata del nivel de preocupación
más bajo porque no se trata ni de una
variante más contagiosa ni de una
variante más grave aquí en américa
latina en brasil están investigando si
hay dos casos de esta variante pero en
todo el mundo estamos hablando de unas
pocas decenas de casos así que por ahora
diríamos que no hay motivo de alarma
pero en europa si tienen la alarma un
poco encendida no en la pandemia a nivel
mundial por ejemplo en ese continente
que le acabo de mencionar en la liga de
sí rosamar perdón no me cambia el nombre
raúl se trata de un crecimiento de casos
de la mano de un linaje específico de o
micro en la b2 que es un nombre menos
llamativo pero en este caso sí es más
contagiosa que la variante omicron
original así se pronunciaba la
organización mundial de la salud
sequence estar vivo de todos los
frecuencias disponibles alrededor del 75
por ciento son a punto 2 y el 25 por
ciento son vea punto 1 todas son omicron
es decir no tienen un patrón de
transmisión pero son variantes
preocupantes por lo tanto estamos viendo
un aumento en la proporción de vea punto
2 detectadas sin embargo la cantidad de
pruebas que se realizan en todo el mundo
como hemos mencionado anteriormente está
disminuyendo sustancialmente ve a punto
2 se ve comprometida porque las pruebas
se reducen no se pueden secuenciar a los
que no se analiza sequence esto
el comité sino que también repunte en
china- mar pero terminamos con una
noticia especial un grupo de científicos
tuvo una mirada única sobre el cerebro
en el momento de la muerte como es esto
pues en realidad pasó de casualidad
estaban midiendo la actividad cerebral
de un señor de 87 años y durante ese
registro tuvo un ataque al corazón es de
las pocas veces la única vez de hecho
que se ha registrado ese momento
específico que se supo 30 segundos tanto
antes como después de que el corazón
parará de latir el cerebro todavía tenía
actividad cerebral y de hecho tenía la
misma actividad cerebral que tenemos
cuando estamos soñando cuando estamos
recordando cuando estamos desarrollando
tareas de alta concentración eso abre la
puerta a muchas preguntas una cuando es
la muerte no es el cerebro todavía está
funcionando después pero también si es
realmente cierto que la vida se nos pasa
por delante de los ojos cuando estamos
en eso de morir importante decir que es
difícil extraer grandes conclusiones
porque solo un caso de un paciente que
además era epiléptico pero
definitivamente esperaremos más
investigaciones alrededor de eso pues y
de esta respuesta tanto biológica como
neurológica de cómo afrontamos como
seres humanos el momento en que se
termina nuestra vida espiritual no más
duele metería ahí esa esa palabrita
queremos que esos recuerdos sean buenos
ojalá seguramente sin más gracias por
toda la información pasamos ahora a
introducir nuestro segundo tema al día